nos encontramos en una estación de
gasolina en el suroeste de Londres muy
cerca de una vía principal lo que lo
hace lo que la hace muy congestionada
que se ha quedado sin suministro de
gasolina desde las 5 de la mañana de hoy
la última entrega de gasolina la tuvo el
domingo a las 10 de la noche y hemos
presenciado que además conductores
preguntan cuándo volverán a tener
gasolina en esta zona y las han tenido
que decir que no hay certeza
posiblemente esta noche pero no hay
Claridad el gobierno Mientras tanto
asegura que poco a poco la situación ha
ido normalizándose por la crisis de la
gasolina aquí en el Reino Unido pero lo
cierto Es como pueden ustedes observar
siguen siguen y siguen llegando los
carros pero no gasolina que tanquear
justamente el ministro de negocios ha
dicho hoy que la reserva de tanques de
gasolina del gobierno ha iniciado su
camino para abastecer las diferentes las
personas de el Reino Unido y se espera
que también en los próximos días
integrantes del ejército empiecen a
conducir los camiones de gasolina Para
poder abastecer el país Lo cierto es que
la crisis no se genera porque no haya
gasolina sino porque no hay conductores
hemos hablado con diferentes personas
que han expresado su temor porque esta
crisis de la gasolina se extienda y que
incluso pueda también llegar a generar
escasez de productos alimenticios dado
que ese es uno digamos de los grandes
temores que se tienen que han expresado
las grandes cadenas de supermercados que
por la falta de conductores en este país
incluso podría haber escasez para las
fiestas de Navidad